so school everyone one thing I admire
about apex Legends is its commitment to
having such a diverse range of
characters at the Sims we've always
believed representation and diversity in
games is critically important perhaps
now more than ever it's difficult to put
into words just how meaningful it can be
to see yourself reflected in the games
you play so here to tell you in their
own words are a few members of our Sims
community it's a very interesting thing
to explain it feels empowering actually
and very moving it really taught me a
lot the importance of just like keeping
relationships good with people it's
probably like the only place where I was
open they get to see my personality
first before seeing my disability I
guess you could say I found myself to be
the only black child in my school I was
discriminated I was bullied my skin tone
my height and my teeth first realized
that I was trans and I had I was like
praying to God to undo it I have this
world where I can express myself and be
myself where I come from Who I am the
color my skin you know who I'm attracted
to let any of that get in the way it was
it was no barriers no matter where I was
or what I was going through I had my
safe place this is plausible this is a
future you can have was almost like I
was peeking into the future and I didn't
know it at the time but it gave me hope
it gave me a sense of hope that I could
build a life that looked like that
The Sims is almost like a utopia of what
I hope our world eventually becomes as I
got more comfortable with my character
in the game
no more comfortable with myself I play
to build neat I play to express myself I
play to make a difference a play to feel
good about myself I play to have
confidence you have to feel my
creativity it's more than just a game
it's creating your life
as you just saw there are so many
reasons why I am proud to be part of the
Sims global community we want the Sims
to be a place of unity and hope a place
where you can be your authentic self and
build your vision for our shared world a
place to imagine what's possible to our
simmers thank you for everything you've
done to make your communities virtual
and real a better place
now I know some of you tuned in hoping
for some Sims news and we'll have plenty
to share as the summer goes on but we do
have one announcement for you we'll be
welcoming players on a whole new
platform as the sims 4 arrives on Steam
today take a look
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]